this is either my best video idea ever
or my worst there's no in between
hi a few days ago i asked you you
people watching right now for your best
of the legend of zelda related pickup
lines
and she gave me some pickup lines all
right forewarning by the way
due to all of your creativity this video
is going to be a little bit less sfw
than normal it's not going to be nsfw of
course but just a little bit more
mature than usual that being said though
for all you
thirsty people out there this one is for
you
i had over 130 submissions on twitter
and
well over 1 200 submissions on youtube
to comb through and i've selected the
top 15 fan
favorites to read to you right now for
your viewing pleasure on today
valentine's day oh by the way happy
valentine's day i hope you're doing well
with your
or or all alone um have good
good day today so here we go are you a
male gerudo
because men like you are only born once
in a hundred years
now that was smooth this was like
melting butter
in a hot tub kind of smooth
also starting this off with a pickup
line geared towards men you don't see
that all the time hey baby wanna check
out my master sword
how did i not see this one coming you
might want to be careful
there the master sword is also said to
destroy evil so it might you know what
i'm gonna i'm gonna stop right there
actually
roses are red violets are blue you've
met with a terrible fate
haven't you i mean
it rhymes i feel like if this ever
actually worked on somebody you might
not want to go out with the person it
worked on
hey you look like you've got some
terrible things going on
oh my gosh what did you say to me are
you a deku nut
because your beauty is blinding ah
because they blind enemies with light
had me in the first half they're not
gonna lie you know with the whole deku
nut part but uh yeah then it turned
really sweet and yes
i say d and thank you in advance for
correcting me in the comments
are you stasis because you can make my
heart stop
okay this one's sweet uh but i i can't
help but laugh because
okay isn't this saying normally like
your heart speeds up when you're around
your crush or something like that
this one is straight up hey are you
stasis because you've stopped my heart
actually i'm dying
wanna go out are you thunder blight
ganon because you've taken all my hearts
now that was creative it does bring back
some pretty bad memories though of hard
mode
[Music]
master i would like to suggest that
there is a 69
chance that i love you
oh no no no no no i shouldn't have read
this one you see
by the way that it's written this isn't
just a pickup line this is specifically
a line
that phi is using to pick up link i
don't remember this part of the game
i was gonna ask you out on a date never
mind it was a long shot anyway
i am a man that appreciates a good pun
that long shot would have definitely hit
his target
did it hurt when you fell from skyloft
because you have the face of a goddess
this one's good unless it's this goddess
this is kali the hindu goddess if she
looks like this
she may have fallen on her face oh okay
this one's a three fur we got three for
the price of one here we go
one are you a bonfire because i could
stare at you for hours
two i could wait a hundred years just to
see your smile again
oh three if i had the triforce you would
be my
only wish how is it possible that these
got sweeter and sweeter i feel like the
first one is what you say to pick
somebody up the second one you say
sometime in dinner to like seal the deal
and the third one is what you say
later that evening
are you a heart container cause my life
meter just extended
whoa it's kids it's warm in here these
twitter people man
they got one thing on the mind it's good
it's good this is this is a good one
solid even lionel's a red ocarinas are
blue
fairies are sweet i've got a heart
that's just for you here's the heart
that's just
for you and here's the one that's for
mitha and for zelda and for marin and
for malon
and forsyto puts hand on girl's shoulder
hey
listen
hey listen what are you looking at me
for write this down
are you being targeted by guardians
because everyone's eyes are on you
are they really oh gosh i hope they're
not gonna
fire their huge powerful lasers at me
you make my sword
point skyward that was good
it is very warm in here and for some
reason i get the slightest suspicion and
sneaky feeling that i'm not going to
make it
to the pearly gates of heaven when i die
what makes this even better is that it's
one of the naughtier pickup lines on
this list and it comes from
the wholesome cat girl miss fushi on
twitter
just a good wholesome pickup line for
the list
are you a korok because i want to
collect your
oh
you just slayed this entire list sir
well done
well done mr nintendo black crisis i
have no words for this little sliver of
perfection i just read
i sincerely hope that people use this
i can't i can't i can't oh
okay well that's it that's all the
pickup lines i'm going to take the time
to read in this video but if you want
some good ones and trust me
there are thousands more in my youtube
community post and hundreds more on my
twitter post
go check them out for some more laughs
there are some really good ones in there
also huge thanks to everybody on both
platforms that participated in this
little project of mine i think the
valentine's day special 2021 turned out
pretty well don't you
and if you're still in a valentine's
mood be sure to check out my valentine's
day special from 2020. i'll link to it
in the description below be sure to
subscribe if you haven't already for
more content
like this but also other kinds of
content like game theories and stuff
like that drop a like if you haven't
below to get this video spread around on
youtube and spread the valentine's day
love and cheer
question mark to everybody out there go
follow me on twitter and instagram and
stuff like that if you want to be a part
of future projects and giveaways and all
the various things that i do
on social media this is mass intended
bandit wishing you a happy
valentine's day with whoever you're with
or not with
and signing out have a great rest of
your day peace
not sure what to do for this outro here
so i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna go back here i'm just
kind of gonna
just gonna be back here until the camera
stops
at any moment now the camera will stop
did you stop it did i stop the camera